NARRATOR: The
following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information
about our license
and MIT OpenCourseWare
in general
is available at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ready to go.
So first of all, to say
thank you to several people
in the class who sent codes
to find these wavefronts when
a shock, a step function is
moving along with velocity c.
I had roughly drawn what
these three methods produced,
but it was much better to see
it in Mr. Sekora's movie that's
on 18.086 site.
And sure enough, behind the
moving front is an overshoot,
that reminds us of the Gibbs
phenomenon, from Lax-Wendroff,
and I think it's sort of
unavoidable if we have
a negative -- because one
of the three coefficients
at the previous time is
negative for Lax-Wendroff,
that's how it gets its
second order accuracy,
and we see that better
accuracy in a much steeper,
much steeper profile.
Then Lax-Friedrichs,
if you've noticed,
has a sort of jagged profile.
Maybe you've realized
why that would be.
Somehow Lax-Friedrichs kind of
operates on a staggered grid.
We'll see, actually with -- I've
drawn a staggered grid here,
so I can say what I mean.
Lax-Friedrichs
computes this value
from the two earlier
values there and then
at the next level
again and so forth,
so that actually, Lax-Friedrichs
is using two staggered grids
separately.
I think -- normally,
with Lax-Friedrichs,
we call that n plus 1 and
n plus 2 and n plus 3,
but the picture is still right,
so I think that's probably
responsible for what you
see, that there's two waves,
two fronts, right, one delta
x away from each other.
And finally, upwind
is also smeared out.
I guess I was so pleased to
see these actually showing
on the website and that makes
me think of more questions.
Maybe you too.
First of all, as
time goes forward,
we see this bump
beginning to appear.
So am I right in thinking that
it reaches a certain height
and stays there?
So I guess I'm thinking about
sort of further questions,
because every time you do
a numerical experiment,
good additional
question show up.
So I'm wondering, as
this wavefront forms,
this characteristic profile
for these three methods,
first of all, does that
profile settle down
to a steady profile?
Ultimately it'd be great
to be able to predict
what it would be.
In particular, does that
bump reach a certain height?
Because you can see it just
barely forming and then
you see it growing
to a certain point.
And then, when the movie
ends, fortunately it
plots this picture and you
really see the profile,
and you can actually
see, if you look closely,
that it goes above 1
again and probably more.
That would be, does it
approach a steady profile?
Does that height settle down?
It'd be fantastic to be
able to predict that height.
For example, you always
want to know, how do things
depend on the parameter?
The one parameter we have
in this problem is r --
c delta t over delta x.
If I change r, I'm changing
all the coefficients.
If I changed r to be
exactly 1, then the profile
would be perfect, right?
That's the golden
ratio, r equal 1.
I would be computing that
value exactly from this value,
at exactly the right slope,
on the characteristic,
and perfection.
Now as r goes away
from 1, I presume --
it goes down below 1.
Of course, if it goes
above 1, catastrophe.
If it goes below 1, I presume
the bump begins to appear,
goes higher.
I don't know.
Could you see how the
dependence on r appears?
And then I can even suggest
one more thing, which is --
let's put a fourth
guy onto this picture,
which would be leapfrog.
Leapfrog for
first-order equations,
so let me just put down
below what that would be.
So it would be on that
kind of a staggered grid.
A new value at
time n plus 1 would
come from these at time n,
really, and this one, at time n
minus 1.
So leapfrog -- you'd
think of it right away.
I use a centered difference in
time, U_(j, n+1) minus U_(j,
n-1) over 2 delta t equals c
times a centered difference
in space, U_(j+1, n) minus
U_(j-1, n) over 2 delta x.
So you see right
away, the 2's cancel.
The delta x times c -- the
delta t times c over delta x is
our old ratio r, so this is
easily written in terms of r
again.
It does have this
two time step issue
and of course, we have
to think about stability.
I'm writing down a fourth
candidate for the equation u_t
equals c*u_x, of course, before
I come back to the second-order
equations, or systems.
I just wanted to put
in these comments,
partly because I'm thinking
about projects that are --
and I hope you are -- so
some people will have theses
or problems from other courses
which involve solving PDEs
and that'd be perfectly
natural to base some project
on, but if you don't have
some specific application,
then here are a whole lot
of interesting questions,
to just go further with that.
So the dependence
on r would be a --
the profile dependence on
r, c delta t over delta x,
would be a question.
Let me just emphasize,
what's the goal?
When I say that this
upwind one is smeared out,
I mean that it doesn't satisfy
what you really hope for.
You want to capture that
shock, that discontinuity --
not perfectly, you
can't expect that --
but you want to capture it,
maybe in, let's say, 2 delta x.
A good method captures
the shock within 2 delta x
and does it without much
undesirable oscillation,
physical oscillation like that.
So these are methods where
we're trading off a good shock
capture versus a smeared one,
which is not satisfactory,
really, in a lot
of applications.
So capturing the
shock within 2 delta
x, roughly, is highly
desirable, and you
might have to go add a
artificial viscosity that we'll
discuss to get there.
So that's past things, but
still very much present,
if I can say.
Here I've introduced
a new leapfrog,
a one-way equation
leapfrog, I'll
call this, where
the last lecture was
about two-way leapfrog.
Leapfrog for u_tt
equals c squared
u_xx, a two-way wave equation.
I might just mention about
this one-way leapfrog,
once you put in e to the
i*k*x as we always do,
or e to the i*k*j delta
x in the discrete case --
so you would put in an e
to the i*j delta x times k,
and then find the G,
the growth factor in --
that'll depend on k and will
tell us the time dependence.
It'll be a G to the n-th.
I think you'll find
that for this guy,
the absolute value of G is
exactly 1 while it's stable.
Of course, if the Courant
condition is violated,
then there's no way
it could be stable
and G's will grow,
be bigger than 1.
But, I think in the stable
range, you will have --
this G will have
absolute value exactly 1.
So it'll be on the unit circle.
You don't have
much leeway, right?
We found upwind was,
like, well inside;
Lax-Friedrichs was well
inside; Lax-Wendroff,
because it had higher
accuracy for low frequencies,
was closer; and I think
this guy is right on.
So this is the
first-order methods.
This would be Lax-Wendroff
and this would
be this second-order method.
So you're really
playing with fire there
and maybe this is
not a favorite, just
because it's too close to
the edge, in fact, right
on the edge.
So those are some
comments really generated
by your numerical experiments
and I think that's the way this
course should -- homeworks and
projects should develop out
of numerical experiment.
Now I'll come back to
complete my lecture
on the second-order
wave equation.
So we studied leapfrog for that.
I won't repeat that, but
then with second-order wave
equation, we have
another option,
which is to reduce a
second-order equation with two
time derivatives to a system
of two equations that are
first order in time and space.
I've chosen to use the letters
H and E as a kind of hint
that we're touching a really
big application, which
is electromagnetism.
So E for the electric field, H
for the magnetic field but here
in 1-D -- so it allows me
just to mention that in 3-D,
when E has three components,
H has three components,
this is really the curl and
this is really minus the curl.
And the notes will show
the beautiful Yee mesh,
staggered mesh that copies
for finite difference methods,
the properties of the
curl, our interpretation
of and the properties of -- that
Maxwell discovered the physics
of, you know, current, magnetic
fields going around a wire that
along which one an
electric field is going.
But let me stay here
with one dimension.
So first of all, can we recover
the wave equation from that?
Let's just see that we haven't
left behind the wave equation.
So I just take the
second derivative --
so the second derivative -- I
just want to recover the wave
equation so that I haven't lost
it here -- so this will be,
if I -- I'm taking the time
derivative of the first
equation, so I get d
second h dt dx, right?
But by the useful, extremely
useful fact that this is
the same as taking the t
derivative first and the x
derivative second, now I
have the x derivative of this
equation, so this is c --
now I have the x derivative,
or c times it, so now
I'm up to c squared,
the x derivative of the
x derivative, right?
So we eliminated H, got back
to one equation, second order,
and it's the wave equation.
I want to show the same thing
now for finite differences.
It's just -- it's such a simple
and useful device and our point
will be that it works for --
just as well for differences.
That allows us to do
this staggered grid idea.
So the staggered grid idea
is, I'll do E on this grid,
at these grid points,
H at the half points,
E again at the integer points,
H again at the half points.
Now, so my difference
method, leapfrog,
on this staggered
mesh, will copy --
so the first equation will
give E at the new time from
the difference in
H at this time.
So, you see it.
dE/dt is going to be replaced
by that time difference.
dH/dx is going to be replaced
by this space difference,
and that will determine
E at the new time.
So I need time 0 and
time 1/2 to get started.
Maybe I put those
down here, somewhere.
I have to use the
initial condition,
the initial velocity to
get started on E and H
and then I go onwards.
I've got to this
point and this point.
Then this guy comes from this
one, this one and this one.
Of course, that similarly
comes from the same equation
shifted over.
Now I know these.
Now I'm ready for this one.
Coming from -- what am
I approximating now?
I'm on the staggered part
of the grid, the half steps.
I'm approximating this on the
half steps, where H is defined.
So that minus that is
the time difference.
This minus this -- which,
I know these now --
is the space difference
in this equation,
and that's what allows me
to compute the new one.
You see, it's a simple idea.
It's close but
different from my scalar
leapfrog, one-way leapfrog here.
Here it was the same
U at all the points.
Here it is E at the integer
time levels and H at the half
integer time levels.
It's natural to say --
I'm calling this leapfrog.
Could I do this for the
difference equation?
I just want to see that
if I eliminate H --
you saw what happened there.
By using the identity that the
second derivative in t and x
is always the same as the
second derivative in x and t,
I eliminated H and got an
equation that involved E only.
What's going to be the
corresponding identity?
Trivial, but just -- trivial
things are not bad things
to notice -- for the
different method.
This is what I wanted to
be sure of, for the H part.
This H -- so the H were -- do
you mind if I draw yet another
symbol?
I want to use this
idea to eliminate H. So
let me put two H's there.
Is that right?
Yeah.
I think what I'd like to know --
let me just say what I believe.
I believe that the time
difference of the space
difference of H
at mesh points is
equal to the space difference
of the time difference of H
at the same mesh points.
I meant to put
these as subscripts.
It's not delta x.
It's delta sub x.
Difference in the time
direction, difference
in the space direction.
Let's just see what this means.
Let me redraw these four points.
These are H. H at
all those points.
So this says, figure out the
space differences -- so this,
this minus this and
this minus this --
and then take the time
difference of those.
Can I see what I'll
get if I do that?
So this means I take
the space differences,
so I have 1 minus 1 and
that would be 1 minus 1,
but now I'm going to take
the time difference of those.
So that'll be this
one minus this one
and this one plus this one.
Do you see that?
What we have here is H
at this point minus H
at this point minus
H at this point
plus H at this point plus 1.
I claim that we have
the same thing here,
that if I take the time
differences first --
can I do that?
Instead of taking the
space differences first,
I'll take this one,
this time difference,
this minus this and
I'll subtract --
I'm taking now the space
difference -- I'll subtract --
are you with me?
You see, it's just the
same four values --
two 1's and two minus 1's,
whether we go first -- in fact,
this actually is a -- I think
maybe throws a little light
on the calculus identity,
that we can exchange the order
of the derivatives, because we
know we can exchange the order
of the differences, because
we just got numbers like 1,
minus 1, minus 1, and plus 1.
If we let the spacing,
the mesh, go to 0, this --
and divided by the
delta x and the delta t,
I suppose we would prove
the continuous case.
So in a way, this throws light
on something that's probably
something that we
take for granted,
but we wouldn't want to
be pressed on too closely.
So having that
identity allows me
to do exactly what I did with
the continuous case there
and show that this, when I
eliminate the half levels,
I've got ordinary leapfrog.
So when I eliminate half
levels, I will be --
when I eliminate this
half level, let's say,
then I'll be connecting --
when I eliminate half levels,
I'm going to be connecting these
at three levels -- one, two,
three.
It'll be leapfrog.
So since it's been a few
days since we wrote down
two-way leapfrog or second-order
equation leapfrog, let me just
write it again, and
that's what we would get.
The time difference
squared of E will
be equal to c squared times the
space difference squared of E.
And of course, here we
have a delta x squared
and here a delta t squared.
So altogether, an r squared.
That's the formula we know.
So if I simplify this
to make it look good
and put the delta
t squared up there,
you see that it's
just r squared.
Maybe it's worth realizing that,
again, the magic r equal 1 --
The magic ratio r equal
1 gives the exact U,
agreeing exactly with u.
This equation, if r is 1,
would be satisfied exactly
by the continuous solution and
so it's the same as this one.
So that's leapfrog.
So can I summarize leapfrog?
Leapfrog was, first of all,
that led us to these --
it worked for
second-order equations.
It led us to the same
stability condition
that r had to be
less or equal to 1,
but it took a quadratic
equation for G. Remember,
we had G squared minus
2G times some quantity
a that involved r's and
cosines plus 1 equals 0.
The reason it was a
quadratic was there
were two time steps involved.
We handled that.
We got stability, if r was
less than or equal to 1.
That led us to a, in
magnitude, less or equal 1.
And that led us to G -- I'll
just remember those steps --
a less or equal 1, and that
let us to G less than or equal
to 1.
Yes, the notes, including
more about Maxwell's equation
and Yee's beautiful method, with
a figure that shows his mesh,
will go up -- I mean, every
section is getting upgraded
and this one is the
next one to be upgraded.
Probably by tomorrow,
you'll have a good section
on second-order equations.
For me, that's what I
wanted to say about the wave
equation alone,
with no diffusion
and now I'm ready to move
to the heat equation.
So what do we have coming up?
Maybe important to
say what's coming up.
So we've done one-way wave.
Now we've done two-way waves.
Next comes the heat
equation, heat/diffusion,
and then will come a
mixture of the two,
convection-diffusion
-- and by the way,
so I'll go straight to these
-- in a couple of weeks,
we'll have a guest lecturer
who will do the applications
to financial mathematics,
mathematical finance.
Specifically, the
Black-Scholes equation.
So you probably know that a lot
of effort and a lot of money
are going into the
valuation of options
and other financial derivatives
and that this Black-Scholes
equation beautifully
produced the heat equation,
and additional
correction terms will
produce a
convection-diffusion equation.
So this is an
application that we
wouldn't have made
some years ago,
but now it's worth
focusing on that.
I think it's
interesting in itself.
So this is what's
coming and then
you could say one-way wave
equations, but nonlinear.
So nonlinear wave
equations and those
are called conservation laws.
That's after these linear cases.
All right.
So I'm ready to tackle the
heat equation, starting
then on to the next
section of the notes.
So let me tackle it here.
So the heat equation.
Let me take the constant
to be 1; u_t equals u_xx.
Because we already see
the big difference.
Now, there's a second
x derivative, but only
a first derivative in time.
The dimensions of t and
x are no longer the same.
We won't have delta t
and delta x comparable.
Now it will be delta t
comparable with delta x
squared, and that's a very
significant difference,
because that's --
if delta x is small,
delta x squared is
extremely small.
So when delta t is constrained
by delta x squared,
we're looking at
small time steps.
We're looking at stiff
systems, absolutely.
This is going to
be a stiff problem,
because the low frequencies
and the high frequencies
differ enormously
in the decay rate.
In fact, why don't
we see it right away,
starting as always
with exponentials.
So if I plug in u of x and t
is some G of t e to the i*k*x,
separating variables as always.
Look for a pure
exponential solution,
plug that in and we get
dG/dt times e to the i*k*x
on the left, and now I have
to take two x derivatives,
so that brings i*k down twice,
so that's minus k squared --
i squared giving the minus 1 --
times G, times e to the i*k*x.
And now, of course, I can
cancel that, which is never 0,
and I've separated
out the time part,
the G part, dG/dt is
minus k squared G. So G
is e to the minus k squared t.
Notice that it's k
squared, and notice
that it's real and negative.
See, that's a very
big difference.
Compare e to the i*k*c*t, which
it was for the one-way wave
equation.
The difference is enormous here.
That's magnitude 1,
energy conserved.
This is magnitude smaller
than 1, energy dissipated.
We had a ratio delta
t over delta x.
Now we're going to see
delta t over delta x squared
because somehow x and
t are -- now have --
it's x squared
that matches t now.
So now, when I put that into
here -- let me just do it --
G of t is e to the
minus k squared t.
So there is the
pure exponential.
Simple as always, because we
have constant coefficients,
but highly informative.
I guess another thing that
I read off of that is,
what frequencies
are decaying fast?
High frequencies?
If k is large, k
squared is very large
and e to the minus k squared
t is decaying very quickly.
So high-frequency
noise in this system,
roughness, discontinuities
are going to get smoothed out,
strongly, by moving
forward in time.
Physically, what's
happening is, we
have our wavefront, which
stayed a perfect step
function in the wave equation,
will instantly smear.
So diffusion smears
discontinuity.
Heat travels.
If we were back over here, if
the temperature starts out as 1
on this side and 0 on this
side, then in an instant,
some heat flows
from right to left.
In fact, it flows
with infinite speed.
In a short delta t, there's
a little heat all the way out
there -- very little, of
course, because it's --
I guess we want to see
what that behavior is.
So I now want to write down --
staying with the differential
equation, what do we want to do?
We did the exponential
case and learned a good bit
from that, the fast decay
of high frequencies.
The next step would be to
put different frequencies,
different k's together.
By linearity, we can
add these solutions,
we can multiply that
by any numbers we want,
depending on k; we
still have solutions.
And we can integrate over
k, so we will, actually.
That that will be the next step.
Let me write down
what that does.
I'm going to jump,
take a little jump here
to put on the board what
I just said in words.
I can multiply this, e to
the minus k squared t e
to the i*k*x -- that's what's
happening to the pure frequency
k.
If I multiply that by the amount
of that frequency which is
in the initial condition -- so
here is the initial condition,
u_0, and I've taken
its Fourier transform.
This tells me how much of
frequency k is in the problem,
is in the initial problem.
This tells me how
much of frequency k
is in the initial problem.
That amount multiplies this,
with this rapid decay as time
goes forward, but at any later
time, I'm just adding up --
and since k -- we're
on the whole line --
k is a continuous -- so we add
up from k equal minus infinity
to infinity and I think we
have to remember the 2*pi that
depends on our particular
definition of that transform,
but I'm going to
stay with this one.
That's the answer.
That's u of x and t.
So I've said that in
words, but actually, we
could just check it.
We would like to know that this
left-hand side solves the heat
equation, and we
would like to know
that it has the correct start,
the correct u of x and 0.
Let's check that.
At t equals 0, at
the start, this is 1.
So at the start, this
formula, without that thing
there, is just the
inverse Fourier transform
that takes the Fourier
transform, multiplies by this,
integrates to recover u_0.
So it does start out correctly.
Should I say that again?
It starts correctly
because at t equal 0,
this is just the inverse
Fourier transform of u_0,
so it produces u_0.
It inverts this
transform that we took.
Secondly, does it solve
the heat equation?
Sure, because for
each k, we've just
found that that solves
the heat equation
and now we're just putting
different k's together.
So that's the answer.
So you might say,
OK, perfection.
Do we need finite differences?
I guess we do.
This is typical of formulas
that give the answer exactly,
but in terms that are not
numerically convenient.
Because, to use his
formula, first of all,
this this requires an integral,
an infinite integral to find --
integral to find
-- for u_0, u hat.
To use this formula, we'd
have to find this transform,
and then we have
to do this integral
for the inverse transform, this
integral, for the answer, u.
Two infinite integrals.
And, not to mention the fact
that on a finite interval,
when x doesn't go all the
way from minus infinity
to infinity, we have to
think all over again.
So we have a nice formula
for the answer, but --
it looks nice, but it's
not numerically terrific.
We can get a lot of
information out of this
and there's one other
special solution that's
also extremely informative.
What if -- so I'm going
to do a special case,
but it's the big case.
What if the initial conditions
is a delta function?
What if the initial condition
An impulse at time 0, x equal
0, an instant source of heat
at a point -- a point
source with finite strength,
you could say.
An impulse at times 0.
For the wave equation,
what happened?
That was like turning
on a flash of light
and it went along
the characteristics.
For the heat equation,
it'll be quite different.
There aren't
characteristics here,
but this is an extremely
important solution,
and I think you could call
it the fundamental solution
to the heat equation.
You may know what it is.
You may have seen this formula.
It's fantastic that we get
a formula for this one.
You could say,
we've got a formula.
What's the Fourier transform,
what's u_0 hat of k
for the delta function?
1, right?
The Fourier transform of the
delta function is a constant 1.
All frequencies are
there in equal amounts.
This is a constant,
so I can remove it.
It's 1.
I'm left with a
specific integral to do.
And the question
is, can I do it?
And the answer
turns out to be yes.
You can do that integral
when this is a constant
and that will give
you the answer
with that starting value.
Let me just say
what that answer is.
u of x and t -- this is
the fundamental solution,
u fundamental,
maybe I should say,
because it's such an important
case -- is, turns out to be --
it's not obvious what
that integral is.
By the way, normally --
let's see -- normally it's --
to get the answer that
I'm going to write down,
we take a kind of end
run on the integral,
and I'm going to take a
serious end run and write down
the answer exactly.
Here's the key
part of the answer.
It's a solution which starts
from a delta function, spreads
of course, and the shape
as it spreads is a bell.
It's the famous bell-shaped
Gaussian distribution of e
to the minus -- so is it e to
the minus x squared, I guess?
And then, always here comes --
that scalar tells us the width
of the bell.
How far has it spread at time t?
And what goes there is 4t.
That's the key observation.
And notice how x squared
and t are coming in.
It's that ratio, x squared
to t, that's crucial.
That's the parameter again.
Of course, we need to
multiply by a constant.
How do I know I need a constant?
Because the total
heat is conserved.
In other words, the integral
of the delta function,
the original source
of heat, was 1.
The integral from minus
infinity to infinity
of the delta function, which
is all totally concentrated
at one point, is 1.
So I need to put on
whatever constant
it takes so that the
integral of this thing
shall stay 1 for later times.
This is one integral from minus
infinity to infinity that we
can do and it turns out to
need 1 over the square root
of 4*pi*t.
That solves the heat equation.
It's not a lot of fun to plug
that into the heat equation,
but it's possible, right?
The x derivative,
the time derivative
is going to be messy.
It'll have two terms.
The x derivative will have
two terms and they'll agree.
The notes will give one
way to do the integral
and get that answer.
You see that that
integral, it's --
integrals with e to the minus k
squared in them are impossible
on a finite interval, but here
we're going all the way from
minus infinity to infinity,
which you might think makes
the problem harder, but actually
it makes it a great deal easier
and we can get an explicit
answer, a beautiful answer.
So we learn that the solution
to the heat equation,
coming from a point source, is a
bell-shaped Gaussian curve that
gets wider and wider
as t increases,
but I guess you would
want to look to see,
what happens if t
comes down to 0?
Does that really approximate
-- I meant to say,
does it really converge to --
this should, as t goes to 0,
this should go to the delta
function, and in some way,
it does.
In some way, it does.
It's wonderful.
The delta function, of course,
is 0 away from the origin.
So why does this approach
0 away from the origin?
Suppose x is 1.
Then do you see this thing
going to 0 as t goes to 0?
Look what's happening.
As t goes to 0, this part is
blowing up, but kind of weakly.
That's not a disastrous blowup.
Compared to this e to the
minus -- let's say 1 over 4t.
As t goes to 0, that's e to
a very negative exponent.
That's going to
0 very fast, much
faster than this is going to 0.
If you like to think of
l'Hopital's rule or ratio
or something, this
quantity is going to 0 way
faster than this one
is, and the result
is 0, except at the one point
x equals 0, where this is 1.
The fact that the total
amount of heat stays at 1
tells us that the delta
function is the limit there.
Today was the heat
equation, continuous case,
with these explicit answers.
Then next time is -- tomorrow,
I guess -- is the heat equation,
finite differences.
Again, we'll have several
difference methods
and to compare them
would be terrific.
Please think about that,
comparison with the heat
equation and/or
what I was saying
at the beginning of
class, a deeper look
at the comparison for
the wave equation.
See you tomorrow for difference
equations for this problem.
Thanks.